foreign
hey you guys here we are again for
another flickers of fear so I can't
remember where exactly I went into this
but I feel like I've talked before about
how maybe Canadian horror movies tend to
be ever so slightly like underrated or
underseen with the possible exception
obviously of maybe like David
cronenberg's movies like everybody's
seen those but I have to say that
especially in regards to the slasher
sub-genre um Canada kind of like punches
way above its weight and I feel like
they're a little bit ahead of the curve
they were a little bit ahead of the
curve on that I mean obviously they were
not only responsible for one of the very
first slasher movies uh 1974's black
Christmas which was released you know
four whole years before John Carpenter's
Halloween but I feel like they also came
up with a bunch of really good
examples of the slasher sub-genre like
you know in the wake of Halloween making
such a big impact like on the horror
scene so while some Canadian horror
movies I feel like have maybe finally
like gotten their due you know so like
My Bloody Valentine prom night terror
train I mean they all have like these
massive cult followings I do feel like
there's one Canadian slasher that
doesn't really seem to get brought up
all that much even though in my opinion
it's actually one of the best of its
kind
um it's a very ambitious movie uh for a
slasher it's a kind of a twisty it's you
know it's filled with twists like it's a
murder mystery and it has like some
pretty decent Gore in it as well has
some kind of bigger named stars like it
both in the movie and behind the camera
and had like a significantly larger
budget than this type of movie would
usually Merit and the movie that I'm
talking about
is Happy Birthday to me from 1981. so
the idea for this movie uh was cooked up
by or maybe I should say baked up like a
birthday cake no Jenny you shouldn't say
that uh but anyway so the idea of it
came from these two producers whose
names were John Dunning and Andre link
and their whole thing previously they
had been working on kind of like Skin
Flicks like Canadian like erotic horror
movies I think they were mostly like
softcore porn you know what I mean uh
and they had been successful at that but
they started seeing the higher
profitability potential of the
burgeoning horror Market that was coming
out like in the wake of Halloween which
made like all the money
so they hired this English Professor
from the University of Toronto named
John Saxton
to kind of like put together a script
Now by this point as I mentioned
Halloween and Friday the 13th had kind
of set the stage like for the slashers
going forwards everybody was like trying
to rip them off so lots of filmmakers
were just jumping on this trend you know
of like a low budget High return horror
film based you know kind of uh you know
targeted toward maybe the teen or the
20s you know demographic and a lot of
them because of the success of Halloween
uh were based around a holiday you know
what I mean you had new year's evil you
had Terror train which I mentioned
before which was also set around New
Year's you had some Christmas ones like
to all a good night which was directed
by David Hess for Christ's sake from uh
Glass House on the Left
uh and then you had Christmas evil
Mother's Day ones like that or they were
some that were like also based around
kind of like a special event you know
what I mean like prom night or
graduation day or he knows you're alone
which was actually kind of based around
a wedding type of thing
so the writer and the producers came up
with this concept which would be focused
around a character's birthday uh they
thought that they would maybe have
Universal appeal because you know
obviously everyone has a birthday and
then they sort of cross-pollinated it
with the idea that the main character
would have kind of like some kind of
brain injury that would prevent her from
knowing exactly what was going on around
her and they thought maybe this will add
like another layer of ambiguity or
another layer of mystery like to the
plot incidentally the same producers
behind happy birthday to me were also
responsible for My Bloody Valentine Now
My Bloody Valentine I think went into
pre-production only like a week or two
after happy birthday to me wrapped but
uh My Bloody Valentine was actually
released before happy birthday to me
like just because to take advantage of
like Valentine's Day they wanted to be
released around Valentine's Day
so happy birthday to me was actually
directed by an oscar-winning director a
British guy J Lee Thompson who had kind
of come up as you know being like this
kind of Classic Hollywood type of guy he
had directed The Guns of Navarone from
1961. uh the original Cape Fear from
1962 so he was kind of like known for
that kind of stuff and then like once
the 70s rolled around he'd kind of been
getting into a little bit more like
genre type movies
um he actually directed the fourth and
fifth movies in the original I planted
the Apes series which I think it was
Conquest for the Planet of the Apes and
beneath the plane I can't really
remember but I know Conquest was like
pretty sure one of them uh but he was
actually intrigued he'd been getting
kind of more interested in Thrillers and
stuff so he was kind of interested to
try his hand at a slasher horror movie
even though you'd think that a guy like
that wouldn't really be interested
also looking for a change of pace was
the lead actress they got to start on
this it was uh Melissa Sue Anderson now
she obviously had become a mega star
because of her role as Mary Ingalls on
Little House on the Prairie which was
like a hugely popular TV series but she
was actually kind of looking to get into
movies I believe this was her first
major film role
and she specifically wanted to get into
something different from the very very
wholesome role that she was most
identified with so she was like really
into the idea of doing a horror movie
now also classing up the cast was the
iconic Canadian character actor Glenn
Ford who was actually in us this was
kind of a small part for him he stars as
you know the main character psychiatrist
essentially
um Glenn Ford was in loads of big films
like during Hollywood's Golden Era like
he was in Gilda from 1946 he was in the
big heat from 1953 uh Blackboard Jungle
from 1955.
and only a couple of years before he was
in happy birthday to me he was uh
Jonathan Kent you know Superman's uh you
know adoptive dad or whoever in Superman
like the Richard donor one from 1978. uh
I heard
that Glenn Ford was apparently a
nightmare to work with uh on the happy
birthday to me Set uh they said that he
was drunk pretty much all the time and
allegedly uh engaged in some fisticuffs
with at least one member of the crew
now because of Canadian tax laws because
remember like there was all these movies
that came out in Canada where they were
like giving people they wanted to like
pump up their uh film industry so they
were giving people like tax incentives
and stuff like that to shoot there but
you had to have like a certain you know
amount of your certain percentage of
your actors and crew had to be Canadians
and stuff like that so because of these
particular stipulations uh Glenn Ford
was actually paid a much bigger salary
than the very small role that he had in
the film would suggest uh and that was
because the main star of the film who
was Melissa Sue Anderson was American
and not create and not Canadian so they
had to have like pretty much most of the
other actors and crew and stuff like
that were Canadian but he they they just
had to do it so like Glenn Ford got the
most money I guess so yeah so the rest
of the cast were kind of then
lesser-known Canadian Actors largely uh
some of whom actually went on to you
know decent or like big Fame litter
later on uh he had Lawrence Lawrence
Dane was in this and he was in Bride of
Chucky later on uh Leslie Donaldson who
was in this she came kind of became like
something of a minor scream Queen I
guess like in the 1980s she was in
deadly eyes from 1982 uh which I think
also had Scatman Crothers in it and she
was in curtains from 1983 which I just
reviewed on here not too long ago uh
Matt Craven who played a character named
Steve in this movie I feel like he
probably went on to maybe the most like
prolific career like he's still around
nowadays like still working but he was
in Jacob's Ladder from 1990 A Few Good
Men Crimson Tide
um the 2005 remake of Assault on
Precinct 13. he was in X-Men first Class
from 2011. so yeah so like I said he's I
kind of feel like he was the one that
maybe was the most successful or
recognizable so the story of happy
birthday to me is a tad convoluted let's
call it that uh and it has like several
twists toward the end the last of which
was pretty clearly dreamed up like part
way through the production because there
really isn't any setup for it but
honestly if I'm be I don't know it's I
to me that just seems like a very minor
quibble um at least in my opinion the
movie I'm gonna say too is also
significantly longer than most slash
removes almost two hours I think it's
like an hour and 54 minutes or something
like that
but in spite of that it never really
seems to drag I mean at least in my
estimation it seems like there's always
kind of something interesting going on
so in the movie we're mainly following
this young woman named Virginia or Jenny
for short and she goes to this kind of
fancy private school called Crawford
Academy which is I think it's supposed
to be somewhere in Massachusetts even
though the movie was shot mostly in
Montreal
um and some of it in Upstate New York
so Jenny is a member of the so-called
top 10. this is like a group of these
very wealthy privileged but popular
students and they all hang out together
and they mostly hang out at this Pub in
type situation and it's called The
Silent woman and the sign of it like has
a headless serving girl which I was like
okay that's a little bit weird
it's a little Macabre like for him to
but you know I guess that's kind of like
a that's a British thing too where they
have like those pubs with this like kind
of [ __ ] up names but that's kind of
like what this one is like too so at the
very beginning of the movie uh another
one of the top 10 people whose name is
Bernadette she gets murdered by an
unseen killer wearing black gloves now
we know right away that the Killer is
somebody the victim knows because
the killer like attacks her in a car and
then she manages like to get away and
you know after she escapes she runs into
someone else who we don't see and she
gives that all oh it's you you know
thank God I'm saved or whatever like
that routine and then it turns out that
that person is of course the killer that
she thought that she had escaped from I
will say too that I do actually kind of
question Bernadette's decision like
after she escapes from this killer who
was up in the back seat of her car like
she gets out of the car but she only
runs like 10 feet and then like hides my
I'm just like keep going because like
get the [ __ ] out of there it's like the
Killer's still right there it's not like
you got out of the car and they like
disappeared or something like that I was
like they're still there and they can
see you like very clearly I just thought
it was very weird that she just kind of
like stayed there I don't know if she
thought she was hiding or I don't know
it was just like really really weird so
anyway uh so the rest of the gang are
back at the silent woman like the pub
and although they notice like
Bernadette's absence They Don't Really
attribute any things Sinister to it
they're like oh you know maybe she found
something better to do or she's staying
over with a boyfriend or something like
that now after they leave the bar
they decide to do this thing which
apparently they do quite a lot and they
call it the game and this is essentially
like a game of chicken with like a
rising drawbridge like all the cars I
think they call out for you know Point
like who's going first and who's going
because obviously you want to go first
because you can go they're ramping the
bridge essentially like while it's going
up so if you call first then obviously
you're gonna get be able to get over a
lot easier and it's like it just gets
harder and harder like I don't know why
you'd want to do that because it'd be
like a horrible death but you know what
I mean so yeah so they're trying to like
jump the gap between the sections of the
bridge like while they're going up now
on this particular occasion the car that
has Jenny and a couple other people and
I can't remember which one of the gang
is driving it she's not driving
um and the the car it makes it like over
the Gap but just barely and Jenny freaks
the [ __ ] out and like runs off into the
wood now they think this is like weird
like what the [ __ ] her deal I'm like
um you almost killed her that's what her
deal is but it turns out that there's
like a deeper thing like going on with
that
it turns out that she had this big
extreme reaction because it had to do
with like the death of her mom
in an accident that happened I think it
was like four years previously now the
details of the event you don't actually
learn what they were until later on
so we know that Jenny was somehow
involved in the accident but she lost
her memory of it completely we also find
out that she has been the subject of
like an experimental treatment that
attempted to I think they're trying to
like stimulate the regrowth of her brain
cells like through electricity or
something like they said like they got
the idea from like the whole
galvanimator thing like with the frog
leg you know what I mean because there's
like a scene where they're in Biology
class and they're doing that so but the
writer said that that's where he got one
of the ideas from like it was some
experimental thing where it's like oh
we're trying to stimulate like you know
shock your brain so there's actually
like a great scene where they basically
like cut her skull open and like take a
piece out and like fart around in there
it's like the special effects are
actually quite good in this
so uh so Ginny is under the care of a
psychiatrist and he's encouraging her to
try to regain her repressed memories of
what happened to her mom but it's also
kind of maybe implied that the
experiment might also be messing with
her perception of reality so as The
Story Goes On uh you get a number of red
herrings red herring type characters but
like you know because it's this big
group of friends you know what I mean
and so you have this one dude that hangs
up and he's kind of nerdy and he has
like a pet rat and he's really into
Taxidermy so you know everybody thinks
that's like super weird you have this
kind of like overbearing I think it's
like a French Canadian jock type dude
who is he's kind of like a little bit of
a stalker type thing he's like follows
Ginny around and like climbs in her
bedroom window at some point like steals
her underwear and then you got this guy
that you know takes her to this weird
creepy like Bell Tower like on a date or
something and like does like Quasimodo
voices and and also he like buries a
skull from the science lab on campus for
a prank while several of their friends
are missing which seems like not all
that wise now because all of these dudes
are so obviously set up as weirdos or
suspicious then you know that they're
gonna turn out not to be the killer but
I mean it's still like I mean they're
still entertaining diversions anyway but
much like this is a little bit like a
giallo movie so it's like the most
obvious guy you know that that's not who
it is I have to say too that the kills
in this are actually pretty fun
um you get like a weightlifter guy who's
like gets his neck crushed by his own
barbell like after the killer like also
like takes the the rack thing away and
then drops it like weight on his crotch
which I thought was very funny
um you have one where like a dude gets
his scarf thrown into like the running
engine of his motorcycle so it like
pulls his face into the thing
um and you also get that famous kill
that appears on the poster of a guy
getting like shanked through the the
mouth like with a shish kebab now it
should be noted that the guy on the
poster is I don't think is even in the
movie you know what I mean that's just
like the guy that posed for the poster
but he's not in the movie
um and is it just like a completely and
it's so it's a different person like the
guy that gets shanked in the movie like
with the shish kebab doesn't even look
like that guy so I don't know it's
really weird now toward the end of the
second act uh it's actually revealed
that Ginny was the killer all along or
was she
uh it certainly does look like she's the
one who for example like stabs the rat
guy and stabs the guy with the shish
kebab like they're not even pretending
that it's not her you know what I mean
because they're just showing her
um but as memories of her past start to
get slowly doled out they're I guess
they're trying to like set up like a
motive for her
so you discover that Ginny's mom like
four years ago invited all the rich
popular kids all the from the academy
like all the ones that are now dead to
Ginny's birthday party but none of them
showed up because they all went to the
party of another later member of the top
ten whose name is Anne who is apparently
like a lot more popular rich or whatever
than Jenny was I think it's implied
kinda that Jenny's mom was maybe kind of
trashy or like Nouveau riche or
something so the other families in the
area were kind of like real snobby about
accepting her and accepting her daughter
so maybe there was like some [ __ ] like
that going on so after this whole snub
uh pissed off Mom puts Ginny in the car
and then angrily drives over to Anne's
house telling Judy well it's your
birthday so you're we're gonna go to
that party whether we were invited or
not
um but on the way there Jenny's mom
tries to ramp the drawbridge during a
storm and doesn't make it hence why
Ginny always like freaks out whenever
they play that game right so the car
actually plunges into the water very far
below in a stunt which I heard
ultimately ended up destroying about 15
cars because they kept like dropping
them and I guess they didn't get the
shots they watered or something like
that
um so yeah so the car goes into the
water and Jenny is actually able to swim
to safety uh but her mother drowns and
after that like she blocks out all
memory of the accident and then like
toward the end of the movie there's a
really great like creepy scene which I
always like really remembered where
Ginny's dad comes across a birthday
party that Ginny has set up uh
apparently with all of her dead friends
and her mom's rotting corpse like
sitting around the table wearing party
hats and there's like a birthday cake in
the middle so we're led to believe that
a combination of finally remembering all
the details of the accident where her
mom died and also the weird [ __ ] that
the doctors did to Jenny's brain like
while they were trying to do this
experiment on her made her go completely
ape [ __ ] and like bump off all the top
10 like in Revenge for sliding her which
in turn caused her mother to get killed
but then the movie throws us for a
complete Loop
by first making us think that Ginny had
a twin because we think like there's
Ginny and she's doing the [ __ ] with the
cake and everything like that but then
like there's another Jenny like sitting
at the table who's still alive but then
they reveal that the true killer was
actually Anne who was wearing an
unbelievably realistic mask of Ginny's
face to make everybody think that Ginny
was the one doing the murders right
so it turns out that Anne who had
actually disappeared earlier on in the
film but whose body was never found
because obviously she was still alive
was actually Ginny's half-sister
Jenny's dad I think had an affair with
Anne's mom like years ago and that just
caused like the whole entire breakdown
of Anne's family when she's like a
little bit bitter about it so so Ann
comes up with this like really
complicated scheme to dress up as not
even dress up as her just like have
because like I said the face I mean it's
obviously it's the same actress you know
what I mean so it's like the best the
best [ __ ] fake makeup you've ever
seen yeah so uh so she's gonna dress up
as Jenny or look like Jenny drug the
actual Jenny so that she doesn't
remember anything
um and then kind of make her think like
she's crazy and she's the one doing all
this [ __ ] and she's like losing her
memory and then she's just gonna kill
everybody including ultimately Jenny
herself and then I guess blame Jenny
posthumously like for the murders
so it doesn't make a lot of sense really
and that's because as I alluded to
earlier this final plot twist was
actually kind of pulled out of the
filmmaker's butts sort of at the last
minute now originally Jenny absolutely
was supposed to be the killer all along
but evidently I think it was Columbia
Pictures who distributed the movie they
were not like really a fan of that
ending for whatever reason so it was
changed like very very late in the game
which means that if you watch the film a
second time with the express purpose of
looking for Clues like hinting that and
was the killer all along uh you won't
find them because they aren't there
because they just changed that at
literally like the last minute I have to
say though in spite of the sort of like
what the [ __ ] ending I still really dig
happy birthday to me um it was a slasher
that I always remembered really fondly
like from renting the VHS back in the
day I mean it's a great cover it's very
iconic and we rented it me and my
brother we rented it like pretty often
like back in the early to mid 80s and I
always remember really really liking it
I think I saw it on cable a few times as
well and watching it now now I haven't
seen it many years but you can tell that
it's clearly more expensive and much
better shot than a lot of it's kind of
like cheapy slasher counterparts maybe
and the acting is kind of like a notch
above too although I will say that I
always thought Melissa Melissa Sue
Anderson and um I think the actor's name
is Sharon Acker that plays her mom I
think they come off a little overwrought
but other than that it's good but yeah I
mean the movie has like some fun kills
and the gore is very very well executed
like I said really good special effects
and it really doesn't wear out its
welcome in spite of it being like much
longer than average for this type of
movie I mean as I mentioned the plot is
very complex and is not really all that
believable like especially like that
last twist but I mean to be honest I
always just kind of took it in the same
Spirit as a giallo movie with you know
the kind of outlandish twists and turns
like that has it's just kind of like you
just go along for the ride and it's like
you know it's not terribly believable
but that's okay um and you know it keeps
you on your toes so I can't be too mad
at it so like I said I feel like
Canadian slashers have kind of gotten
some appreciation in modern times I
still feel like happy birthday to me I
it just doesn't seem to get the
recognition that it deserves so I kind
of hope that eventually
um it'll sort of take its rightful place
among the ranks of other beloved can
exploitation uh slashers like I said
along with black Christmas and stuff
like that because it really is quite
good uh especially for a slasher so if
you've seen it let me know in the
comments what you thought about it
actually at the moment I believe you can
watch it on 2B for free at least as of
this recording so if you haven't seen it
maybe go check it out and tell me what
you thought about it and that will do it
for this flickers of fear I'll see you
guys again on the next one bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]